this is unbelievable
yeah I know it's a little strange yeah
Frank tomorrow morning
you're gonna go to the bank and draw 1
million dollars out here account and the
puss to account number eight I sew down
my stenographer Applejack oh yeah watch
me jack
somebody's coming out of this yo man
look Christ the hole right there guys
stay right there three on this way come
here the only thing connecting us with
the case is in the back of your car
which is parked outside make us to 700
quid I'm not gonna fry them away and
there are delighted try some back to us
are they do you really think it's worth
taking the risk for 700 pound Tom you're
a dick now you take those guns and you
throw him off a bridge and throw
yourself off while you're in what you're
engaged in is blackmail that is a felony
that's restore ders secondly the
unauthorized dissemination of classified
material is a federal crime
if you ever carried out your proposed
threat you would experience such a
shitstorm of consequences my friend that
your empty little head would be spinning
faster than the wheels of your swing
bicycle back there you dig that's a
Schwinn what do you mean no Clemmie you
know that me oh you can't do did you
chief I've never heard of dog sweetie
you know you know what I do when I'm mad
Paul I hit a pillow just hit the pillow
see how you feel
that's your [ __ ] pillow feel better
yeah I do
hmm this is your homework Larry ask him
about the car man it's just yours Larry
this is your homework lever your car out
front is this your homework Larry we
know it's his homework where's the
[ __ ] money a little brat look Larry
have you ever heard of Vietnam
oh [ __ ] you're entering the world of
pain son we know that this is your
homework we know that you stole a car
and the [ __ ] money and the [ __ ]
money and we know that this is your
homework I cut your dick off laughs
you're killing your father Larry all
right where are we all right cashmere
it's not your idea of making a
contribution
I ain't even started we've even gotten
to the times in this close to losing
okay I don't even understand what
happened in there what did I said hey he
called his niece a [ __ ] very cheap on
what she's seven currently confined to
bed with a wicked case I think that you
are bluffing
right now are you what you're doing well
what I'm doing for the guy who likes to
bluff is I'm playing a little game
called and I love thing huh where is she
where the COS harmony Harry we play
hardball I can do that where is the girl
what did you just do just I put in one
bullet tonight put a live round in that
gun oh yeah there was like an 8% chance
what is this eight eight yeah who taught
you math you're the only guy I'm still
under guard my executive Sales Manager
well you can help me my name is Marge
Gunderson father-in-law he's the owner
uh-huh well I'm a police officer for my
Brainard investigating some malfeasance
and I was just wondering if you'd had
any new vehicles stolen off the lot in
the past couple of weeks
mr. Lundegaard Brainerd Houma Paul
Bunyan babe the Blue Ox babe the Blue Ox
so you haven't had any vehicles go
missing no no no ma'am
okie dokie thanks a bunch of let you get
back to your paperwork then
Oh